we've been preparing our whole lives for  this day  come on future guardians of lingard it's  just up ahead  we welcome you our first year students  i'm going to be so great at  [Music]  if your magic fails you you will forfeit  your guardianship  [Music]  everyone draw your weapons polish and  sharpen your minds  your reflexes  you've got to be brave if you want to be  a guardian i don't know if i can do this  you're going to be a perfect guardian  [Music]  i'll never give up on any of my friends  [Music]  my mom she went off on some mission but  she never came back  mommy is the level of magic in the earth  fading  we have to undo this why are you after  [Music]  us  team fighting girls join the battle we  are  not calling ourselves that  you